字幕: Iria Verdugo
校正: Hiroko Kawano
皆さんの人生で
一番の障壁は何でしょうか？
受験でしょうか？　就活でしょうか？
仕事での大事なプレゼンでしょうか？
私たちが生きている中では
様々な壁がありますが
それら全ての根本的な要因
それは恐怖、不安、恐れ —
そういった感情ではないでしょうか？
皆さんも 今までの人生で
恐怖で足が竦んでしまう
そういったことはないでしょうか？
私は今日この場に立ってお話をするのが
とっても不安で 足が竦んでしまいます
大勢の前でお話をするのは 今日が初めてです
「緊張して 話が飛んでしまったら
どうしよう？」とか
「最後までお話しできなかったら
どうしよう？」と
不安で不安でいっぱいです
では なぜ人は恐れるのでしょうか？
どういったときに 人は恐れるのでしょうか？
先ほどお話しした 受験や就活
それらに共通して言えるのが
自分の未来を決める選択をするとき
人は不安になるのではないでしょうか？
自分の未来がここで決まる
その未来が大ききれば大きいほど
そして その選択が重要であれば
重要であるほど
人は大きな不安を抱くはずです
では 選択をしなければ
人は恐れないのでしょうか？
本質はきっと違います
選択をしなければならない状況に
恐れているのではなく
選択をした先が分からないから
恐れてしまう
先のことを考えても 分からないから
人は悩んでいる
そして 選択をすることと
切っても切れない関係にあるもの
それが時間です
大体の選択には締め切りがあります
宿題、仕事、提出物、税金の申請に至るまで
世の中って締め切りだらけ
よく言いませんか
「時間に追われている」って
私なんか いっつもギリギリまで
締め切りに追われます
明日納期だ　どうしょう？
明日テストだ　勉強してない！
明日 TEDxのリハーサルだ
全然練習できてない！
もちろん 早めにやらなきゃって
分かっているんです
それでも なぜかいつも
直前になって焦ってしまう
皆さんもそんなことはないでしょうか？
しかし 時間は平等で有限です
やはり 私たちはこの限られた時間の中で
未来について 選択をして
いかなくてはなりません
だから 「時間は大切です」と
言われるわけですが
時間が大切ですというお話は
もう耳にタコができるぐらい
聞き飽きたと思いますので
本日は この有限の時間を
どのように捉えて
また どうやって選択をしていくのか？
そういったお話を してみたいと思います
皆さんの抱える不安を 少しでも軽くしたり
また 求める未来に
明るく進んで頂けるように
そんな思いで 今日はお話をしたいと思います
少し 私の話をさせて下さい
私がどうして時間に対して
真剣に考えるようになったのか？
私は以前 ハウスメーカーで
おうちを作る営業のお仕事をしていました
おうちを作るというのは
とっても大変なんです
お客様によっては ご予算やご要望も様々
建てる場所によっては
法律や条例も関わってきます
あっちを叶えれば こっちが叶わない
こっちを叶えれば あっちが叶わない
では 全部盛り込んだら
予算がオーバーしてしまいます
それだけではなく
各ご家庭の抱える様々な問題や課題を
解決していかなくてはなりません
ハウスメーカーのお仕事っていうのは
おうちを作るだけではなく
そのご家庭の人生にも
関わっていくようなお仕事なんです
おうちというのは
数千万円する「人生に一度」と言われる
大きなお買い物です
営業初心者だった頃の私は
そんなお客様のお買い物を
本当に安心しておうちを
建てることができるのかと
不安で不安で仕方なかったです
しかも 期日は刻々と迫ってきます
迫るたびに 心臓が「ギュー」って
なるような思いなんです
そんな状態でしたから
完成したおうちを見たお客様が
「あれ？」ってなってしまうような
出来事がありました
お客様が
「山中さん 扉の色が綺麗な白色ですね」
「はい とっても綺麗ですね」
「山中さん 私 茶色で
頼んだはずなんですけど」
「やってしまった！」
もう頭の中も真っ白です
もちろん 全て取り替えました
そういった失敗を経験しながら
また仕事での経験を積み重ねるにつれて
どんな無理難題が来ようとも
なんとかなるかと
思えるようになっていったんです
私の中で 何が変わったのか？
それが 時間と選択に対する考え方でした
そんな考えで働いていると
色々な人からお仕事の相談を
受けるようになります
そのうちに 私も
色々な仕事の話を聞いていると
私も色んな世界を見てみたい
可能性を求めていきたい
そんな気持ちになりまして
今サラリーマンを辞めて
事業を立ち上げました
今とてもワクワクしています
そんな希望や野望に溢れる反面
事業で失敗したらどうしようと
不安で悩み 眠れない日もあります
それでも私が毎日進むことができる原動力
それが時間と選択です
では この時間と選択とは何なのか？
どうすれば悩みや不安に
立ち向かうことができるのか？
ここで皆さんに
２つ 質問をしたいと思いますので
一緒に考えてみましょう
では １つ目の質問です
皆さんは 時間について
本気で考えたことがありますか？
時間には 大きく分けると
「過去」、「現在」、「未来」
この３つに分けることができます
では この３つの中で
確実に存在するものはどれでしょうか？
そして 確実に存在しないものは
どれでしょうか？
私は このように考えております
この瞬間 確実に存在しているのは未来です
そして 確実に存在しないのは現在です
「何でや？」と思われる方も
いらっしゃると思います
確かに現在・今というのは
広義的な意味では存在します
例えばこの TEDxの
始まりから終わりまで
しかし 私は現在・今というのは
この瞬間を確実に切り取らない限り
存在しないと考えております
あるのは ただひたすら
やってくる未来だけで
それはこの瞬間すぐに
過去に変わっていきます
この瞬間 訪れているこの身近な未来は
遠い未来と密接に繋がっています
それはまるで 映画のフィルムの
１コマ１コマのように
現在・今というのは
遠い未来の端っこなんですね
では ２つ目の質問です
こちらも一緒に考えてみましょう
恐怖、不安、恐れ
そういった感情の実体は 何でしょうか？
これは冒頭でもお話をしましたが
未来が分からないが故に
起こってもいない失敗に
恐怖を感じている状態
それが 恐れや不安といった感情の原点です
この２つの質問を整理しますと
我々には常に未来がやって来る
そして
未来の 起こってもいない
失敗に対して恐怖を感じている
きっと やって来る未来が
絶対に成功すると分かっているならば
恐れることはないでしょう
でも そんな世界は存在しません
逆に私は思うんです
未来がどうなるか
全て分かっているとしたら
それはつまらないですよね
どうなるか分からないからこそ
私たちは自分の力で
悩みや不安を乗り越ようとし
その結果として
自分の未来を創っていきます
自分の未来に対して
夢や目標といったものを
明確に描いている方もいるとは思いますが
中には目標といった
堅苦しい言葉ではなくても
漠然と「幸せで楽しい人生を送りたいな」
そんな風に考えている方も
多いのではないでしょうか？
私もその一人です
私たちが未来に対して
どんな思いを抱こうとも
今この瞬間も 未来は一歩一歩近づいて来ます
その中で 自分が思い描く
未来に対して今できること
それが 先ほどお話しした時間と選択です
さらに言えば
ただ選択するのではなく
どう考えて選択をするのか？
今 何をすべきか？
目の前の未来をどこに踏み出すかで
たどり着く未来は異なるはずです
大切なのは
起こってもいない恐怖に
目を向けるのではなく
目標を叶えたい
夢を叶えたい
幸せで楽しい人生を送りたい
そういった願望に目を向けて
そこに近づくための選択をすることです
ハウスメーカー時代
営業初心者だった頃の私は
起こってもいない未来の失敗を想像して
自ら恐怖を生み出していました
満足いくおうちが
建てられなかったらどうしようと
しかし 経験を重ねて
時間と選択の考え方を
取り入れることによって
「何とかなるか？　いや 何とかするぞ」と
いう考え方に変わっていったのです
つまり 起こってもいない
恐怖について考えるのではなく
私はお客様の営業担当者として
どんな無理難題が来ようとも
お客様の満足行くおうちを建ててあげたい
安心して 住んで頂きたい
そのためには
どう行動するか？　何を選択するか？
そういった考えが
自然と身に付いていったのです
脱サラして 未知の分野で
事業を立ち上げている今も
私が何とか毎日進むことができているのは
「事業で失敗したらどうしよう？」と
そういった恐れについて考えるのではなく
私はこの事業を通して
たくさんの人に喜んで頂きたい
この事業で世の中に貢献したい
そういった未来に向けて
選択を積み重ねているからです
皆さんも大切な試験や就活など
そういった場面の時に
「良い点数が取れなかったらどうしよう」とか
「この会社に入って
活躍ができなかったらどうしよう」
そういった不安について考えるのではなく
テストであれば「良い点数を取るぞ」とか
「今 勉強しているのは
将来 こんな役に立つかもしれない」
就活であれば
「この会社に入って 様々なことを学びたい」
また 「こんなサービスを生み出して
世の中に貢献したい」
そういった未来に目を向けて
そのための選択を積み重ねてみて下さい
「因果応報」という言葉の通りです
小さな一歩の積み重ねが 未来を作ります
小さな積み重ねは 後に結果となって現れます
その結果は 数分後かもしれないし
明日かもしれない
１年後かもしれないし 10年後かもしれない
それでも あなたの選択行動が
未来を見据えたものである限り
その積み重ねは 確実に繋がっていきます
ただ 普段の生活の中では何気ない選択 —
そういったものも溢れていますよね
いくら未来を見据えていても
どちらにするのが ベストなのか
迷ってしまったり
「そんなに未来に対して
重要ではないかな」といった選択
そういった時にどうしたらいいか？
今日は１つ アドバイスをしたいと思います
そんな時は 貢献を心掛けてみて下さい
小さな貢献でも
相手を喜ばせることができれば
回り回って大きな報酬となって
返って来ることがあります
小さな貢献が生むもの
それは「ありがとう」という言葉です
その言葉を聞いただけでも
とっても嬉しく思いますよね
そしてその「ありがとう」が
繋いでくれたご縁が
遠い未来で 大きな成果を生む繋がりになる
そんな可能性も秘めているんです
最後に
過去は変えられません
しかし 未来は誰にも分りませんが
自分の手で創ることができます
未来を創るのは 自分自身です
どんなに困難な状況であっても
諦めず 自分の選択を考え続ければ
必ず 未来は変わります
求める幸せのために
今 何を選択し
今 どう行動するか？
この現在・今は 遠い未来の端っこです
今日 私が緊張と不安の中
最後までお話をすることができたのも
時間と選択の考え方で
皆さんの未来が 明るくなればと
考えたからです
ぜひこの考えを 皆さんの人生に
役立てて頂ければ嬉しく思います
ありがとうございます
（拍手）